e depois que eu fazia errado um dia
desses negócios ele não tava com os
amigo no posto tomando cerveja aí beleza
terminar uma me pagar aí eu fui pagar
com cartão acaba disso não depois desse
horário que não paga mais que um cartão
só no dinheiro entendeu um táxi botei no
GPS banco 24 horas aí falamos 24 horas
para longe para carai negócios 35
minutos mas tinha que pagar o negócio
precisava ir no caixa 24 horas mais
próximo pegar o dinheiro foi o táxi já
conversamos apoio eu não se Claro tem
que ser feliz não for chegando no lugar
era um banco 24 horas que ficava dentro
de uma farmácia que fechava meia-noite a
farmácia porque eu
desgraça mas como é que eu ia reclamar
preparar certo banco tava ligado tava
tudo aceso dentro da farmácia que fechar
à meia-noite a farmácia toda apagada e
só o banco 24 horas ligado a ver ele
tava certo que ele não tava desligado
ele tava 24 horas a farmácia não tá
tendo podia ficar ponto com ninguém nem
com caixa mesma faz massa porque tava
certo eu vou ir nem comigo porque não
tinha ninguém